[Music]
all their site website Squarespace
wisbeach website website red face red
face website website Squarespace Westby
can stress with squares with Squarespace
is website that you can get some cool
that temple and we have websites brain
is blue with white give to website a
side of my website website Squarespace
where's based website website red face
frisbees website website Squarespace
Westby Cannes France with Squarespace
squirrels Percy ruse squarespace.com
promo code hey get a great website
[Music]
hello hey what's happening I'm Hannibal
Buress
and so Tony trim this is the first ever
live record another handsome rambling
podcast I could tell a lot of people
like we don't listen to that but uh we
wanted to check this out and I'm fine
with that we've noticed we haven't done
a live one and I was I planned on doing
a live one and then they just said and
you want some money to do a live when I
was like I guess we're doing a live one
I guess we're gonna figure it out but
smile I've been to a bunch of South by
Southwest us West's West self myself
West is's how do you say whatever I
scroll events events I've been to a
bunch of them it's interesting man I
have a good time I mean how many have
you been - I've been with you the whole
time I went to whatever you went to we
never know but oh how many in general
have you been so been too bad
three first one was a nightmare because
I yeah the whole van from Chicago and
then stayed with a bunch of people took
the van from Chicago like a van from
Chicago and then I played for like a
half an hour and then I guess that's it
that's a lot that's what we're doing
that's what perform it is performing is
I've flown to Africa how long is that
flight 10 hours I flown to Africa 10
hours to go talk for a half hour but
there was money involved in that one
yeah it was a lot of money yeah
it definitely definitely in definitely
ours a cop you know job is a job you
know we got we all here just doing the
Lord's work I'm doing the Lord's work
trying to make the best of what I can in
this climate
I like being down here even though it's
chaotic I haven't been drinking having
drinking a couple weeks that drinking
here it's a goddamn nightmare
so I cope with lots of Molly and cocaine
yeah and you was broke yesterday too
I almost broke yesterday I didn't do any
Molly a coke but uh dinner with
strangers it's a different level of fan
intensity here it's South by Southwest
very high to put you on their snapchat
for that 47 followers and just very so
different I'm happy to do it but it's a
different I don't like people are
entitled and aggressive about it yeah I
just want person they said oh man we got
a do this come on I got any like you
didn't even ask me you just kind of made
it like I'm a building to some [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah we bout we doing this [ __ ] like hey
actually you know what no we're not ah
you always gets uncomfortable to when
they do the armor on Michael strangers
grabbed me when I was doing my DJ gig
yesterday or some dude on stage he like
I guess my jacket he liked it he was
like Oh Hannibal with this jackass like
stop touching my [ __ ] jacket
who's this guy security that was a crazy
crowd last night though here's a crazy
crowd I had a DJ gig last night a DJ
under the name DJ Berger feet and really
I really want to be a DJ I just do this
comedy [ __ ] to pay the bills but DJ it
is my true passion I just think that's
what the true path that God laid out for
me things just aren't working out how
they work out they don't they don't see
cuz I decide no my DJ career now working
out cuz promoters won't put just my DJ
name on the flyer they won't this put
deeds a burger fee they'll put DJ Burger
feet then in parentheses they put
Hannibal
DJ says it's okay I deal with it it's
been crazy out here
you know my favorite South by Southwest
story I tell it every year this has
happened one time I'll stand on maybe 25
30 minutes north in a hotel because
everything was booked up and uh so I
have to get a taxi and get in the taxi
and I guess is where you gonna say I'm
going to 6th Street he said I can't get
you to 6th Street I can't get you the
six rings it's way too crazy on 6th
Street it's impossible to get your 6th
ring there's no way we're getting you on
6th Street
it's insane on 6th Street I say ok where
can you get me to that 7th Street 7th
Street totally clear we're all right all
right well this is I'm excited thank you
all for coming through to this I'm very
excited thank you to our sponsors
Schlotzsky's Schlotzsky's they got
brisket beef brisket like brisket
brisket Schlotzsky's Schlotzsky's
Schlotzsky's brisket if I know you can
probably you know just because of
statistics there are some people in here
the vegetarians or vegans so I wonder if
they're conflicted about being at an
event that sponsored by Schlotzsky's no
that's the things we have to deal with
in life
you're winded dogs go from like people
using a dog my dog is my best friend and
now people like I'm a dog mom when if
that should happen I when was a
transition I'm a dog mom I never would
agree with that I always thought that my
dog is just an awesome roommate really
yeah never I never did that that's my
daughter and my parents those are your
grandparents I don't do that [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] weird yeah I don't have a dog I
just refer to dogs as beasts yeah fair
enough
beasts that uh just chill beasts that be
step Medoff in your house yeah sometimes
depends on what kind of doggy exactly
they make yeah you think you think
seeing-eye dogs know that the dude is
blind I don't think so man I don't think
they know I think they just kind of just
training they don't think they don't
know that the guy's blind they just
think they take way more walks than
other dogs my thoughts on that we walk
like seven times a day you just go once
to take a [ __ ]
I walk even when I don't have to take a
[ __ ] wait so if a seeing-eye dog shits
does the blind dude have to pick up his
poop like I was along their community
[Laughter]
I'm blind oh sorry about that sir I
guess I'll pick up the dogs yeah that's
the road if you see the seeing-eye dogs
getting hurt you have to pick up the
[ __ ] I think actually when I see [ __ ] on
the sidewalk oh my god what's the bit of
laddoos dog
now I'm get mad okay that's fair I think
that's fair stuff man
alright we gotta bring on my first guest
of the evening South by Southwest
veteran just a good friend of mine just
just a funny honest crazy dude
please welcome to the stage Byron Bowers
everybody by with Milo yeah so pirate
pirate Bowers what up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's up fire Bowers South by Southwest
we back
Byron Bowers yes the terrorizes city
yeah man by bowels represent for all the
people that wear skull caps in 80 degree
weather that's right
I call my council [ __ ] out there how's
it going man it's going great man I'm
back here some by foot third four feet
here it's beautiful
love this love this venue - this is
justice I perform there doing the most
gruesome times you know me and I love it
gruesome like what remember when the
barricade happened and then 23 people
got hit the to do that yeah don't that
crazy what the [ __ ] I kept getting them
text I can't go to text messages like
people I mean you know it's an awful
memory but I think it's weird to people
just started booing like the drivers in
here yeah like the drivers in here like
the driver was in here feeling good
about himself but that was my first
South by Southwest experience you know
me all the text messages are you okay
I'm like I'm fine but my car is [ __ ]
up
[Applause]
never get these bodies off of my goddamn
car yeah Rosie my insurance don't even
cover got them it's tough out here man
it's tough what's all cost we performed
that was his last performance
oh no you was there remember that wasn't
there you was that I wasn't yeah I'm the
dark friend with the dark fondest
memories no I've never seen him live but
he's a he's a solid comedian yeah it's
very funny yeah it's a great show
it's out of here man I'm surprised he
made it to the stage that was the luck
getting to the stage was longer than
this show it was like watching one of
those movies where you root for the the
animal to make it yeah he was just like
going to the stage like this and [ __ ]
and that's when I was like damn man this
Superman was human that he would be like
that too I mean all [ __ ] up and [ __ ]
have you ever fallen while approaching
the stage yes yeah wait I don't remember
the exact date yeah but I have you know
I didn't ask for the exact date you can
probably it's the ones with the steps
that always [ __ ] you up yeah yeah well
you think there's four steps and it's
five but you always come out hike like
I'm about to [ __ ] this [ __ ] up and then
you jump extra early and it's like an
extra step and you fall and you got a
roll out of that [ __ ] and act like I did
this on purpose
yeah sometimes I'll hit the stage and
out I'll grab the mic out all cool and
slick but then that [ __ ] be tangled
around my ankle
then I have to spend my first but you
won't but you all go cordless either
right you're like what is it about the
court did you always gotta go because
the thing about having a court on the
mic is that if I don't have anything to
say I could distract the crowd like this
form of it having some motion oh yeah
yeah you ever be [ __ ] that is a go-to
it's like it's like a nice crutch in
there you're like [ __ ] like yeah what
what is the fun
what is our fondest show what is almost
remember we shall we know we've done a
lot of oh man the craziest show can I go
yeah
San Diego State oh [ __ ] I born the
hardest bomb yeah it's like the San
Diego State Aztecs or some [ __ ] like
that yeah I walked on stage like why
would y'all name y'all school mascot a
group of people that was massacred like
how do y'all expect a win after this
yeah the whole school turned on me yeah
they didn't like that and I thought I
could get them back so I just kept going
I talked about slavery and everything ha
ha ha ruff and in Hannibal was up after
me and once I finally threw in the towel
I remember walking on stage that
Hannibal was like [ __ ] why
didn't you get off ten minutes ago
he went along he didn't he did in his
time and it was a a you know I don't
think it's happening and you making it
tougher for me you were Bob it was it
was terrible but this fight happens it
happens to all of us and you yeah you
just went probably 10 minutes over I was
furious and sweating yeah yeah you got
off yelled and then I got onstage and
then I started making fun of him for
bombing like hey that guy that's right
and I'm like ha ha ha and I started
going for a few minutes then I started
bombing
and I bomb terribly good I had to do way
more time than he had to do to get my
money yeah and if so when horribly I was
sweating in dry mouth and very nervous
and then uh finished up the show and I
could tell when the promoter gave me my
check he wasn't happy about the amount
of money he had to pay me like this was
not worth that that's what I would like
to get paid before the show you know I
mean I like to be like let me work for
it cuz you give me money before the show
I'm like this could go either way I
don't trust myself I'm right you know
what those two loan people will write
about me promoter try to shyster you out
of some money
Oh at the love I get paid not yet
they still pay me out the pocket and
they gotta write you a check either I'm
a my old [ __ ] this is the next level
nice but I did the promoter here did fly
me JetBlue and I had the smallest TV
screen ever the plan was old as [ __ ]
they played The Jeffersons the whole
time why this is some [ __ ] and he
flew private jet I think that a [ __ ]
hey man listen he might have a
sponsorship for something he did it was
nice hey hey no no but still sound like
you hating a little bit no it was just
weird I'm watching The Jeffersons and
[ __ ] Jefferson's is a solid sitcom man
not on the plane tonight
what did you want to watch something new
you know I mean something where people
fly like something where people like a
Marvel movie on some [ __ ] like that with
superheroes not [ __ ] Jeffersons have
you seen Logan no I want to see it
No yeah you got a lot of demons I don't
want to spoil it for you but since I got
demons [ __ ] it I don't want to spoil it
for you well there's a lot of people
with holes in their faces after the
words yeah cuz it's our Raiders and
again they go in Gori you go in yeah it
gets it gets intense
was it a sex thing though that we see
Wolverine pull that thing out that's all
I'm saying haha did he fall gonna
19-foot my every wondering like what
these mutants [ __ ] like be honest you
have a you always think like that
mystique got some good [ __ ] I know that
[ __ ] didn't go from wet to dry to
[ __ ] cold or hot y'all we never
thought that [ __ ] before
well [ __ ] y'all I think I bet you Trump
thought about it yeah that's why he
[ __ ] president right there got expand
your goddamn horizons I don't know if
this the pleasant old ass mystique
goddamn I'm guessing with it Wolverines
case after he comes he's like I'm ready
again oh that's a superpower for you
right away
multiple orgasms that's why he's so
frustrated he never took a car nap
before never took a calm now that'll
make you angry than a [ __ ] give
him back needle took a car nap before
and that Nick dick magnetic some bout
magneto dick I'm just drawn to I don't
know how you like my big no when you
flip it over to the older side what
about now
you got a different polarity now this is
great right here successful first part
live show well we're we're only 10
minutes in I like it and go wrong okay
I'm sorry
apologize you know you excited to see
anybody any bands or musicians or
rappers out here absolutely not I'd like
to come not knowing what's happening and
then me and Hannibal go out and be like
you know such-and-such playing I'm like
oh [ __ ] that way I'm never disappointed
you know me so I'm excited that
everybody's here and I get to choose
it's like a buffet I get to choose when
your friends are celebrity cuz like in
2014 we just couldn't walk into any show
right but now we pulling [ __ ] off I'm
like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] we get back in
this show it's not that smooth for me
cuz I'm not I just got a I can't get
right into a place I just got to stand
around and wait for the right person
yeah yeah no no come up and be like how
does go girl like you want anything like
now I'm good
you want anything no I'm good you worry
no ha ha ha last year Hannibal was
trying to lean back smooth all knows
like a beautiful lady was walking by and
they had them rails and remember you
that's not what happened whatever they
were watching to change yeah that's
right
watching to change from Alana and his
girl was dancing on me oh yeah she was
dance no she's backing that [ __ ] up on
me and knocked me back on the railing
and the whole rail the metal rail
use it swell down block cows hahaha
that's how that's how that girl was
throwing it back at him
she had ass we was watching out the side
me and another girl was like god damn
she giving it to him
she won't this dick tonight this
bowlegged dick ha ha ha she was throwing
that [ __ ] man and I kind of was relying
on a railing and instead of my own
strength and that should be a lesson to
the rest of you use your own power don't
worry oh no sir
don't put no structures in your don't
let no structure try to hold you up yeah
your own structure
don't count on man use what God gave you
that's a tough thing to play off though
when you get knocked down why dance yeah
you can't cause like a little trip you
could sign it play it off yeah oh no I
was just starting a jog and but you get
knocked down like that in the real world
is practicing you know pratfalls and
such you know got always be working your
craft there's a Denver Colorado Denver
Colorado we did a show yeah I had some
some juice with weed in it oh yeah yeah
lasted 24 hours that's right you were
[ __ ] down in that [ __ ] - yeah y'all
came in the room with with banjos and
guitars and [ __ ] yeah wake me up and I'm
just like what the [ __ ] am i the
shoulder next day and I remember it all
really do we like that and I remember
being on stage and telling jokes like
did I tell that joke already and I'm
talking about killing the cops in front
of the police but I'm extra paranoid and
[ __ ] that's the best time to talk about
killing cops is they can't react right
there
and my favorite time to talk about time
I found myself getting judgmental in in
weird situations nah I hit up this girl
to hang out and she told me she was at a
concert in Chicago and I knew the only
big concert happening was ariana grande
cuz the Bulls and the Blackhawks weren't
playing so that mean the concert was in
the United Center
ariana grande and if you want to meet up
afterwards
and I said nah cuz I don't want to hang
out with you with your post
Ariana Grande vibes I don't know I don't
even know what her concerts like but I
don't even want to see what it does to
you we went and saw Ani DiFranco in the
st. Louis with a bunch of with a couple
random girls that was pretty weird like
sure ani DiFranco yeah let's go see on
TV Franco's next door fine things you do
when you try to smash you sit through an
ani DiFranco sit concert and act moved
by that [ __ ] yeah what's the weirdest
thing the weirdest thing you've done the
smash before the weirdest thing I don't
know there's so many like just being
like out of my personality what was like
I normally don't do this but [ __ ] it she
got she got titties you have to give me
a minute to think about this one
yeah when I was Corden yeah
someone were you just trying to [ __ ] it
somewhere you court yeah my
ex-girlfriend when I was courting her I
just flew out she was she was doing some
work in Vegas and I just flew out to
Vegas to uh to meet up whether it's a
surprise er and I hit her up when I got
the Vegas and she while I was flying to
Vegas
she was flying back to New York so I was
just in Vegas but I flown with Somali so
I just took some Molly and waited watch
looper by myself
and so forever the movie looper has a
special place in my heart because I
watched that [ __ ] high as [ __ ] like this
movies dope what incredible concept
Bruce Willis is killing it Joseph
gordon-levitt for Oscar didn't even get
nominated Liu bros dope as [ __ ] you know
what else is dumb as [ __ ] Schlotzsky's
brisket sandwich let's eat beef brisket
equal or better it's over brisket /
Jesus the looper of meats can I get the
money please hey pal hey Bobby hey pal
the handsome Rambo zero its bimbo the
hot [ __ ] I don't know I'm still PayPal
or what mo is owned by PayPal I like
honestly I'm old-school I like to walk
the chick into the bank and looking
[ __ ] in the eyes I slide it to
him I like doing that [ __ ] product of
long period of time I I couldn't go to
the bank yeah but now I just be walking
up in there but I mean give a [ __ ] I'd
be that dress no draw zones it's been
that [ __ ] right yeah I'm back your
neighborhood comedian they think I'm a
robbed the place they don't know what
the [ __ ] over there do you have a flirt
with a bank teller
oh no cuz I is too much information in
there about me you know man yeah you
know why cause like if I don't I'm cheap
so she can't look at my bank account and
I'm gonna take another some [ __ ] as
restaurant Oh mean I mean so I really
just a regular black girl right they'll
even sound right sorry ladies I'm still
working on this I'm new to feminism so
new to feminism working out the kinks
oh I do dishes and everything you know
alright before before we let you go man
what is your biggest regrets in life
it's an animal's favorite question ask
people randomly I think a college yeah
yeah thank college man College gave me
hope
what'd you major in the college I was
electrical engineer major and I switch
to business management but when you
graduate you still got to go back
amongst your family so it's like [ __ ]
but I moved all the way to California
you know me and now I don't see them
[ __ ] no more except that last trip you
know that [ __ ] was crazy yeah but um
yeah College me I think I could have
spent that time doing other [ __ ] like
you know working on my hip-hop skills or
you know I mean banging chicks getting
locked up yeah cuz you get locked up
young they let us go depends on what you
do but now that's now them out here
while I'm trying to live my life they
like nah we don't get you ten years I'm
like [ __ ] you should know better mother
yeah trying to be good the whole time
and I realized I don't get you nowhere
now let me lay up a little bit but nope
can't be in my forties in jail jacking
off they don't look right on your resume
when you get out there's another man in
the cell next to you you jack off at
church you look at the person like this
help me get there quicker Jesus but this
is okay so let's all just be thankful
that we're in this room instead of jail
and think about that think about that
with tomorrow or this weekend when
you're watching a terrible band or some
rappers trying to hand you their mixtape
mix CD just think yeah I don't want to
add this interaction with this rapper I
don't want to see this terrible but my
biggest fears and enjoy y'all night [ __ ]
Tony
Oh funny guy
oh this episode is sponsored by
squarespace.com make a website get to it
you have a business are you our artist
do you have a restaurant they make it
very easy for you squarespace.com promo
code Hannibal get 10% off your first
purchase 10% now you got 90 to go and
you got to cover that [ __ ] playboy or
Playgirl 90% on you I'll give you 10%
off you put in my first name
Hannibal H a double in IB a
[Music]
interesting question we see people that
are awfully in prison is usually that
agent is now using using but probably it
happens probably in Asia
yeah like Cambodia probably happens you
know where's all Asian people yeah then
somebody gotta be wrong
yeah it'd be a different story ladies
but over here you get benefit out of
doubt but like in like correct cuz I'm
Korea if I'm a thousand Korea since
tattoos are illegal yeah I'd probably be
like a target where tattooing is illegal
tattooing yeah legal is illegal in South
Korea that's even in good Korea even in
the good career it's [ __ ] weird man
it's a little well it's not both is
legal it's a weird Lupo's legal if you
have a medical you have a medical degree
but like who wants to be a doctor to be
a [ __ ] tattoo
we wants go to med school wait you have
to be a doctor to perform tattoos yes
that's the loophole so it's like if
you're tattooing you're probably not a
doctor you know what I'm saying what's
the thought process behind night is it
just we don't know it's not like we
don't want our people to you know how
the fool [ __ ] they don't like it damn
they don't like it like if you can't get
jobs that you can get like fired for
just getting a tattoo yeah it's [ __ ]
up man
so if I was there they probably think I
was a criminal right and that's why your
family moved over here yeah I want my
kids to grow up be able to have tattoos
nothing is [ __ ] yeah everybody has a
different motivations
you know I like this is this is fun cuz
this is it's like doing a stand-up show
but without the same pressure yeah
because if joke doesn't go over my it's
a podcast yeah pretty much
it's a pilot if the joke doesn't go over
that was I wasn't even trying to do a
joke I was like trying to channel Ira
Glass vibes let's try to give you all
information it's been fine doing it
weird 16 episodes or so had it several
guests on I'll be I wonder if I give too
much up in my life you know the talking
[ __ ] you have to you know feel time and
then you end up telling telling stories
and yeah and so didn't you know I'll
tell a story in a person that was in a
story I won't say their name but they'll
I I heard that story and that felt bad
well you did that though yeah yeah
[Laughter]
no sometimes you get sometimes you gotta
force your friends to reflect sometimes
you you know have to force your friends
to reflect yeah that's what a good
friend does what a good friend does and
what better way to reflect then when you
have an escape risk ha
beef brisket beef brisket Schlotzsky's
Schlotzsky's all right we're gonna bring
on our next guest this is this is a
last-minute booking but that's the magic
of South by Southwest you find out the
people are in town via social media
people reach out and then you want to
come through this yeah I'm doing some
[ __ ] two doors away from there I'll just
walk right down legendary hip-hop
artists I've been a fan for years it's
gonna be great to talk with her please
welcome Todd live quali tell ya
Talib Kweli Tyler Carly stop party
people what's up man all right what's
happening what's up
thanks for doing it man hey man you know
podcast podcast it's the new [ __ ]
podcast what use is it to when you avoid
in your job right people stick people
stop listening to radio not really
podcast right they don't buy music no
more thank you
podcasts all streaming man you gotta
earn the streaming yeah you gotta get
that a hundred thousand streams you get
twenty dollars that's right yeah that's
right if you want to if you want to sell
a single for a dollar 29 on iTunes yeah
if I was to make a dollar 29 or Spotify
you have to listen to the song 200 times
to put your Spotify stuff on repeat that
supports your artists but you've taken
you you have your own label yes you Oh
quali Club thank you for that plug
Schlotzsky's
brisket yeah we sell yeah
briskets at quali Club yeah I'm a shout
out to Ryan Leslie he built my platform
Oh Arby's singer slash a Harvard
Graduate / you to star Ryan Leslie yeah
you know he has disruptive media Ryan
Leslie calm but he tracked me down he
said you need to have your own website
where you sell your music and sell your
wares I have I have a bookstore there
and Kiera books and sell books but
really it was in a mold of like Aziz and
Louie CK thinks they was doing and I was
watching the comedian's cuz comedians
you don't have to have a producer or a
beat you could just say something out
your brain and you can sell it right and
I was like how does a rapper do that but
having to pay producers and everybody
else to the engineers and everything and
you know shout to Ryan Leslie quite
quality club.com is the same
people when I'm Louie and Aziz put out
there they're self-produce specials for
$5.00 and that time people would say you
should also do that how about why don't
you do that because because I can't and
we have different situations right now
you know I actually bought something
from a quali club yeah I remember that
you saw my you could I saw the email see
if you buy it from that's how I'll be
catching people in a lies yeah they'd be
like I supported you what you what's
your order number get that confirmation
number yeah I think thank you for no
problem I tried to it was a complicated
download thing and somehow yeah it was
yeah we still working out the kinks use
a couple steps it was it was something
I've needed to spend more time doing it
but then you know I got a TD man right
use like I could just hear this [ __ ] on
soundcloud just gave up but I did I did
support and as though you know quality
you we talked about this in person a
couple times hear you argue on Twitter
for a long time for a long time cuz I'm
following a long time ago Oh argue with
a stranger yeah man absolutely ask me
why um a lot of reasons yeah one as a MC
yeah
the a hundred and forty character space
is a good exercise is a good sparring
session like 140 characters that's like
two bars maybe three bars so Twitter
just for me as a writer you know if you
on Twitter do you like you over 30
honestly cuz if you
Twitter's like 30 40 Facebook's like 50
60 snapchat Instagram I was like
teenagers 20 and all that yeah that's
real you know
um if you want you know for MC 140
characters it's just golden cuz I have
very high minded concepts and wordy
things I want to say and I'm a very
loquacious individual yeah so for me to
be able to fit it in 140 characters
that's the exercise but like I say to
people who ask me this on Twitter I
don't speak to these people I speak
through these people right so I know the
difference from when I'm arguing with
like like I get death threats often you
know I get people calling me [ __ ]
telling me they gotta hang me from a
tree I know the difference from when
someone is really like got a gun and is
really a Nazi who goes on Breitbart or
Stormfront or someone who's just like a
gamer or anime fan it's just trolling
for the lols like I know the difference
I can see it from how they come at me
but when I'm speaking to those people I
convince and change people every once in
a while I'd do that okay I do I convince
people to change and change their ways
but that's not why I do it that's
happened happens because a lot of people
do it because they don't are people on
Twitter like especially a lot of those
gamers and those anime Nazi fans who
have like anime pillows and [ __ ] like
that that's a culture like 4chan and all
that like they don't really mean to be
Nazis you know that's just a status quo
to culture as white supremacy so go on
ya know so you know there's a difference
between someone who's really really
really on it and someone who just don't
know any better
and it's not for them no it's for us
it's for my million and so followers who
will follow in a conversation
it gives them tools to give some
information and man [ __ ] racism an we
exposed him and like I have no problem
yeah and I enjoy I regularly okay
don't really enjoy III came up in in
Brooklyn if building with the gods in
the Earth's 5% philosophy building
destroy show approve she all proved to
the knowledge God
like what's today's mathematics if you
don't show approve you might get punched
in the chest I think that's not one of
your songs I'm like is he by the punch
don't improve wait what does that build
the map was the knowledge that's like
you know that's like that's like the
language of the five percent nation yeah
now I'm not five percent I'm not but I
grew up in New York City and I was born
in seventy five I was raised through
eighty late 80s 90s hip-hop so a lot of
it if you were in New York was
influenced by the five percent nation
which is like Clarence 13x he left from
the nation to Islam and he started in
the streets and in the jails five
percent said we think about whoo tang
clan Busta Rhymes
KMD brand-new being like poor righteous
teachers all these are 5% dudes
everybody in New York who came out
either was at that time was either
Muslim or 5% and I dabbled in that when
I was a teenager John forté is a good
friend of mine he's 5% so I was into
that you know um I was hanging out a
Forte and ol Dirty Bastard the see
knowledge from tickle planets who's 5%
so that's the that's the that's how I
came up and we used to argue and debate
in the street yeah and you had to show
and prove he had to be right and exact
if you if you couldn't have present
evidence and show that your facts was on
point you might get some sort of
punishment from the older guys I was a
younger guy they will beat you up with
that you gotta be right an exact wrong
hey that's I said I'm not father said no
boy I said I dabble that was like hold
on a hour pack our podcast would be
weird as [ __ ] if we just punched each
other every time we were wrong that's a
terrible interview quick
it was a lot I feel like I'm doing that
was my Eric Andre so you're a rapper
what's man like right now how does that
work I grew I grew up man I grew up I
had just [ __ ] our wax-like way back oh
[ __ ] it was a physical comedy you know
anything frapp will get to see that no
but I had to [ __ ] a wax way back
reflection eternal black star final is
great I feel like vinyl is making a
comeback the music industry was in the
red a couple years ago and it got it to
the black because there's a lot of what
did he call our Millennials so
millenials young people and people will
just discover music who are understand
that that mp3 is just compressed and
vinyls making a comeback and I think
that's gonna be the next thing like
people really appreciating vinyls as an
important thing especially for hip-hop
have you have you seen yourself your
vinyl sales going up yeah I mean quality
club.com is really for the vinyl you
know yeah I'm so digitally to iTunes so
what are you guys gonna have a Blackstar
reunion
um we have a Blackstar reunion often
like a few times a year
oh yeah we get paid to do shows and it's
like it's a Blackstar reunion that
happens like five six times a year I'll
talk about the new album there you know
what Yasiin Bey has completely removed
himself from the record industry to
recording and so you know I've do you
know and I've that isn't that is a very
uh I don't know you can't bring him to
the quality Club what is uh what do you
be up to he be in South Africa in
Tanzania I thought it was Tanzania until
I went to visit him he was like no one's
Tanzania oh so for real you just rock
Owens educated you hit that quiet cuz we
don't get that we don't talk about
Tanzania that much
when it does come up it's been tense in
tanzania that's right so you can thank
Schlotzsky's for that information
beef brisket brisket shot information
pronounced African countries correctly
Wow sandwich yeah he got a new record
out called December 99th with his man
Ferrari Sheppard and it's not a most
African it's like there's a group thing
so he's sick you know it's a good record
you know it's a good record black star
is a beautiful thing we just did a few
shows at the Kennedy Center in DC it was
great Brussels ich Rick out in Denver we
trick it we juice now herb IRA talk
about the weed juice I was like that's
accurate I think I was I think I was on
some weed pills yeah some weed pills and
I went to see his show and your openers
she's from Chicago
yes hey shout to K Valentine she's doing
some some showcase somewhere that I'm
not at right now you know but I hope
she's doing a good scene I've seen it
seen it I seen it I know where she's
gonna do know I know I already know yeah
yeah I don't have to be in every single
one know the song right she probably
glad you're not there no she'd even want
me to yeah she said go to Hannibal sting
he for Chicago how'd you discover um
SoundCloud no she are actually uh she
came backstage and I did a show of
Chicago at a at a venue uh what's the
name of the venue I remember I didn't
show she cause she came backstage and
she said I've I'd adore uninvited
uninvited like a money foe guarded
backstage yeah and she said hey you you
like you a great rapper I want to meet
you I was like hey
how you doing like yeah yeah cuz she's a
good-looking young lady all right so you
like okay right I was like I just I
still got it I still got it
no this is completely professor right
and I was like she was like you know um
she was like yeah I'm a rapper I was
like that's dope um I have an
after-party yeah
you want to come laughter party was at
my hotel okay I had a big don't get me
wrong I had a big huge hotel suite for
that day and I just a double bedroom
right it was a band show my band was in
town everybody coming to my hotel come
through she came through she's like yeah
I rap I was like okay let's hear your
songs and I she played me a record and I
was I was blown away
nice I was blown away and we've been
working ever since her album is coming
out April 7th it features myself
BJ to Chicago kid tweet and uh Styles P
though nice hey tell if you remember
that crazy-ass after-party we did once
no no where is Chappelle's room what's
what city
it wasn't Detroit there's asteroid O's
it's Roy MGM Grand
yeah yeah we had to MGM coked-up psyche
as a Raekwon lyric Cuban Linx sorry
I don't do coke no no Jeff no judgments
I love Cuban Linx they was sniffing
through the whole album I love it we
want sod ball tour in 2013 we throw it
so I'm thinking it's gonna be this
raucous crazy [ __ ] strangers and we get
up to the big suite and it's only about
eight other people there and there's
turntables and big wait DJ yeah a DJ for
a I lived Poly's is DJing mr. Pell's
and you're a good DJ - holy shelling it
like not spider the rounds
wasn't no DJ pleaser blended he was
blended and [ __ ] like it was a real
crowd there now our you were working an
eight-person crowd like it was a
thousand person room like I'm giving
some rock that was a great tour huh look
out way I had a Kevin Kevin Hart on that
tour and uh and he told me he was
backstage at a show at San Bernadino
thank sano uh Mountain View yeah
Mountain View California and they said
to me he said to me said so that's the
shirt you decided to wear this upset the
[ __ ] out of me yeah cuz I know Kevin but
um I don't know you like dad but are you
being funny oh okay yeah but follow-up
question what shirt when you wear it was
it was it was a pretty bad shirt yeah it
was you had to take that he gave you I
had to take that you know cuz it's like
I put on a shirt I'm gonna tell you
before I went I put on a shirt and I was
like should I wear the shirt it's just a
comedy show nobody yeah you can't smell
yourself yeah sometimes you don't know
when you're you just got to take those
lumps you took a fashion risk I did and
I was like I'm gonna be backstage ain't
no am I gonna see me it's just a fam
here come Kevin her
has there ever been a move that you made
well a career move or a big decision or
something in your show that you tweaked
it and you did that and then you said
yeah several times yeah I was in
Australia once and went to Australia and
I'm killing it and I'm Robin and I
rabbit you know sometimes in stage B hi
yeah and the crime just the show is
amazing yeah it's so amazing I'm like
i'ma jump in the crowd a rock but not
like not like it's not like stage dive
or like a job but just know just get in
the crowd like it just which was the
tope I'm in the crowd rockin yeah I may
cry off it rocking and then I had to get
back on the stage and I caught a charley
horse in the back of my thigh as I'm
trying to cry climb back on the stage so
I just kind of ribs is that a word with
ya like RW RI ta
rift yeah like yeah like like like I was
like um oh man it was like I was like
species and you had to fake it I just
laid there on the stage I just laid
there I was laying on a stage to the
point where the crowd was a hush fell
over the crowd they were concerned about
my safety
wait were you still rapping while you're
Alayna I just explained to them listen
on shore for three weeks what a charley
horse
I need more vitamin D but your back I
just had to I got up and had to walk it
off for the whole United walk a crap off
yeah but while I'm doing this show yeah
you know you do that cramp walk like
that yeah yeah cramp walk stuff
sometimes I've done that at the end of
my show I have a song sometimes that I
do called gibberish rapping and
occasionally depending on hi the stage
how high the stage is
doing my sound check I'll look I'll see
is this a jumping stage or this a stay
off stage and now if I was up but then
sometimes it's a jumping stage but it is
tough to get back up yeah at the end of
the show I'm just you know right the
next time I'm just gonna take the stairs
these young calves be running and
jumping and such yeah I can't skip it a
hopping skipping people don't realize
how tough it is you don't use a hike man
do you um no my DJ is pretty good on
ad-libs but no I don't have a hype man
yeah people cuz you know why people have
hype man because they'd be out of breath
yeah man that's real and they oh [ __ ]
you get this one cuz I'm out of breath
that's real like I do i do all my big
songs at the end of the set not because
they're the big songs but because I'm
out of breath by that time and you want
the crowd they know the words good
insight into set structure right y'all
are you already know this position with
the next show I want to see that [ __ ]
who do you see um I saw who Tang Clan
yeah pretty good I saw the far side okay
which is interesting because you know
the far side they don't get along all
members all four members so there's so
so Imani a Roman Jewish set they travel
and then fat lip and trade travel but
they bolt they all use name far side so
it's like the dark-skinned far side and
the light-skinned far side I sort of
dark-skinned far side yeah which parts I
do you like bone weight you know what
these different things cuz dark-skinned
farce I've got like like Roman got the
voice like
Romine got dad and he mighty good his
flow but trick is saying yeah you know
fat lip is like the best like lyricism
yes missus it's different things you
know it's different things but I mean I
wish they would you get off that
[ __ ] me personally but I don't I
don't know what I'm like that to even
tell them man I would never say it today
face I just say it on the podcast well
and hopefully they hear it like fourth
party well you just said it through a
pitchfork headline Molly tales far side
get it together
stop [ __ ] around did you sit together
it's for Tom I didn't know that conflict
yeah man it's hard because farce our
first album they was like Michael Ross's
if Jean he's given us I wishes and it
was like so flower it is like your mom
and is like passing he was really happy
great yeah and the second album was like
every time I stepped to a microphone I
put my soul or too much real today I'm
even known anybody sophomore I would be
about how [ __ ] up the music businesses
yeah every time it's De La Soul as
Daisy's second album De La Soul is dead
as to do two separate duels yes hey
music business and festival buyers you
need to step up how much money you are
for a far side that's right exactly
I'm sure that's right I'm sure there's a
amount of money that'll make them
because I'll tell you this yeah there's
there's recipes ol Dirty Bastard is
non-members of wu-tang I guarantee they
don't all get along but I bet you they
get that check there's worth wu-tang's
[Applause]
you walk this way I walk this way that's
my favorite part of when people are
rapping together on stage when they when
they wrapped together in the middle and
they're one person go to the left side
and any other person goes to the right
side you know that's not random I'm like
great stagecraft
working the entire stage I appreciate
that
great spacing and blocking I tell them
you see so you got obvious you got a lot
of insight in the hip-hop community the
question I've always want to ask
somebody with your kind of insight so
what is up with MF DOOM it's a good
question it's a comedy crowd right this
is this a comedy club all right MF tomb
is the Andy Kaufman of hip-hop oh yeah
definitely
MF DOOM because MF DOOM if you know he
comics and I really don't but if you
know your comics doom is the villain MF
DOOM it's a supervillain MF DOOM
sometimes does not show up at his own
shows yeah I've been to three of them
right Doombot yeah I toured what MF do
with the Doombot are Wow I told what
we're doing okay
yeah real do if y'all MF DOOM was a
rapper he wears a mask and sometimes he
won't show up at the show it'll be
somebody else with a mask right who
won't figure it out too the third song
right he calls him doombots doombots
every Tommy Tommy said he said listen um
I said why you sometimes don't come to
the show that's a legit question because
as an artist we're not required to be
professional
we're not professional is for a customer
service as an artist you pay for what
the [ __ ] you get that's just the truth
it's not a requirement like you're not
guaranteed a good tom when you pay for
this live podcast if you happen to have
a good time that's great we work hard
but you're not guaranteed a good time
you know that so you get what you pay
for which is an experience for better or
for worse you can also pay for
Schlotzsky's so yeah beef brisket
[Applause]
Laskey all right so so doom his answer
to that question was I don't leave any
money on the table but sometimes it's
not enough money so what is not enough
money I send the impostor yeah that's
what he's what he saw send me a pasta I
said but listen isn't that wrong yes
another legit question and his answer
made perfect sense he said I'm the
[ __ ] supervillain yep and I'm not
your friend
he never said you don't like me I'm the
villain yes it's wrong I'm the bad guy
so what yeah you said that from day one
I'm a super fun I'm a super villain yeah
so you're paying for the experience of
dealing with the super villain if you go
to if you pay to see a super villain you
might get the impostor oh that's dope I
like that he's an actual crazy person
have you met you you have you like sad
dog show with a mask off oh oh listen
I've listened I know I know dill first
if you're a fan of third base back in
the days get the gas face he's in that
video MF DOOM is from a crew call cam D
yeah cam T isn't it for long I love
recipes to sup rock that was his brother
his brothers sub rock passed away when
they had a record deal they first out
came out they had a soul called peach
fuzz peach fuzz peach fuzz as MF DOOM
his brother daddy J sir brach passed
away recipes and he kind of retreated
away from the music business and he had
a bad experience where they had the
picture the [ __ ] the sample image would
alive through it dante roy's famous ANR
signed them and everything the label
east-west Records Elektra Records would
put out the album with that record cover
so MF dooms whole experience with the
music industry back then his name was
Zev love X he had a nose ring glasses
his five percent his five percent dude
you know I'm saying like his whole
experience in music industry was very
very ugly his brother passed away so he
reinvented himself as a stripper
he's like I'm still gonna come out make
music but I'm gonna do it as the villain
as I move - he said he came to destroy
rap and build it back up right yeah okay
that's intense
is it dark is dark Andy Kaufman right
he's got a he's got an actual super
villain like origin story telling jokes
it's at his DG she's pop yeah I just
like to travel everybody
thank you so much wali Club calm Thank
You Man
Talia Poli well hey that was fun sounds
real good it's a great talk good insight
no you got anything else to say no slaps
keys I guess that's right do we say it
enough to get paid if we did is gonna be
some problems there's been fun hey
thanks a lot yeah thanks a lot
Sabah Southwest
goodnight totally trim and Hannibal
Burres see y'all later all right
[Music]